I'm sorry can I just say something real  quick listen I I really don't understand  I'm just gonna sound so misogynistic  right now I'm so sorry about this but  like no no I really don't understand  women these days now it is so clear that  there's someone I'm not saying it's the  government or Illuminati whatever in it  but there's something going on where  people are just trying to push women  into this industry where you're gonna  have to work you're gonna have to be  this boss [ __ ] or whatever and like  understand this the only people would  have changed since 1950 are the women  you feel me that Madeline imma keep a  rule with you right now and ladies on  the panel take this in this game  London really appreciate traditional  things you feel me that no I'm sorry to  bring it to myself but my girl was very  traditional and the reason I am so  faithful to her is because she is  traditional you feel me